foreign
welcome back to Harry Potter Theory
don't let their modest home fool you
because the Weasleys are one of the
oldest and proudest Wizarding families
in Britain and through all the centuries
of their existence the honest bunch of
do-gooders have racked up quite a number
of interesting Feats and facts today
we're going to take a few moments to
look at some of the most shocking ones
10. related to The Potters The Wizarding
community in Great Britain is famously
tiny although there are over two dozen
purebred families that populate the Isle
and exponentially more Half-Blood ones
that still only amounts to a few
thousand Wizards and witches until
recent times even the most Progressive
Wizarding families believed that
purebloods should only marry pure Bloods
and even if they didn't believe this
pretty narrow-minded point of view many
witches and wizards ended up marrying
other Wizards and witches anyway the
fact that they went to a magical school
and lived amongst other witches and
wizards all but guaranteed that they'd
only marry other magic users with so few
families it was only a matter of time
before the Weasleys married into the
Potter family or vice versa of course
eventually Harry Potter and the Weasleys
would become related by Harry's marriage
to Jenny but according to the Black
family tree another Potter marriage that
predates Harry's by several Generations
meant that Harry was actually already
related to the Weasleys although it
hasn't been confirmed one of Harry's
distant ancestors a wizard by the name
of Charles Potter married into the black
family and produced a child in the 1940s
or 50s through the black family jealous
became distantly related to cedrela
Black who was of course Arthur Weasley's
mother nine related to the voldemorts
and everyone else and actually Arthur
Weasley's mother said drella meant that
Arthur and the rest of the Weasleys were
related to just about every other family
in Britain through the years the blacks
became famous for their lack of male
descendants each generation seemed to be
filled with more and more girls and
since the blacks were infamously
conservative these young black women
seemed to only marry and two other pure
blood families and like we said earlier
there were only a handful of purebred
families in Britain at the time So
eventually one of the black girls
married into the Weasleys when cedrilla
black and Septimus Weasley wed they
produced Three Sons one of which was
Arthur Weasley and through their father
Arthur Ron and his siblings were related
to not just the blacks and The Potters
but also the long bottoms the malfoys
the Tonks the lupins the lestrangers and
even the riddles yes that means Lord
Voldemort 8. Weasley's wizard wheezers
even though Arthur and Molly were
reportedly poor their children went on
to become quite successful each one
became one of the top individuals in
their fields from Bill's work as a curse
breaker to Charlie's achievements as a
dragonologist the Weasley succeeded
wherever they went but one of the
greatest Weasley successors was Fred and
George's sharp Weasley's wizard wheezers
it was a magical joke shop that was so
successful they eventually opened a
storefront in Diagon Alley after the
conclusion of the second Wizarding War
this store produced enough income to not
only lift George to the upper income
brackets but the rest of his family as
well of course none of that would have
been possible if Harry Potter hadn't
loaned them their initial seed money in
the first place
7. serious blacks disowned cousin Arthur
Weasley's mother cedrella was actually
discerned for marrying into the Weasley
family even though they were one of the
Sacred 28 their love for Muggles was so
severe that the head of the black family
couldn't fathom allowing Weasley's
children to run through their Halls so
just as they had cast out so many
relatives before them the blacks Outcast
sadrella although the alienation from
her family no doubt hurt Arthur's mother
deeply she seemed to live a happy full
life with her husband Septimus Weasley
6. even more Weasleys now we don't want
to trust gossip but according to rumor
the Weasleys have always had a lot of
kids when compared to other Wizarding
families who averaged two to three
children per marriage Ron's six siblings
certainly seemed like a lot and that
number wasn't limited to Arthur and
Molly's Union the generations that
preceded Arthur's marriage were are also
rumored to produce a great number of
kids although by the time Harry and
Hermione married into the family the
Weasleys seemed to conform to the rest
of Wizarding society as they only had a
few children each
five one Galleon at one point Arthur and
Molly were rumored to be so poor that
they only had a single Galleon within
Gringotts Bank of course this is
probably just more gossip and bullying
from the malfoys but there is an ounce
of truth to it among the sacred 28 the
Weasleys were in a particularly tough
economic situation and when we look back
through historical records there's
really no reason for Arthur's lack of
savings his mother as we know was cut
off from the blacks which meant that
Arthur wasn't given a chunk of that
family's wealth and the Weasleys had
only produced male descendants four
generations according to traditional
male favored rules of inheritance the
Weasley Sons likely had to divide and
share the inheritance that their parents
and grandparents Left Behind reducing
their family wealth each time and since
Arthur Weasley took a job as a Ministry
worker which didn't really give him
enough income to support seven children
it makes sense said the Weasleys
struggled
for one of the Sacred 28 the sacred 28
with the 28 remaining pure blood
families in Britain by the 1930s as
usual The Wizarding families of the time
were overly concerned with the
Half-Blood status of those around them
although there were a handful of
progressive Wizards who didn't care
about Mughal Heritage most of the
Wizarding World in Britain was
absolutely obsessed when sorting out
suitors and upcoming marriages parents
would often refer as the list of the
Sacred 28s in order to select an
upstanding family for their child if you
take one look at the list it's hard to
imagine the Weasleys got along with many
of the members there were the malfoys
the strangers and crouchers to name a
few interestingly even though James
Potter was supposedly pure blood The
Potters weren't included on this list
because of their outspoken sympathy for
Muggles 3. blood traitors in fact The
Potters weren't the only ones who bucked
the trend of pureblood obsession
whenever the Weasleys were mentioned
along with the other sacred 28 they
often publicly criticized the
distinction they would point out the
many mughals who were rumored to be in
their ancestry a fact that Arthur
Weasley was particularly proud of due to
their muggle sympathy the Weasleys were
considered blood traitors a slur
reserved for those who married
non-magical humans or simply betrayed
the belief of wizard Supremacy 2. the
great Wizarding War even though Arthur
and Molly never joined the Order of the
Phoenix their lives were deeply impacted
by the first Wizarding War during that
time they kept their heads down and
focused on providing a safe home for
their brand new family almost
immediately after getting married the
pair started to produce Children First
was Bill then Kim Charlie Percy the
twins Ron and of course Ginny bill was
born in 1970 and Ginny was born in 1981.
that meant for 11 years there was always
at least one infant in the Weasley
household which must have been
terrifying with Voldemort and his Death
Eaters roaming around Britain after all
Arthur Weasley was proudly sympathetic
towards Muggles and it wouldn't have
been unusual for Voldemort to attack the
Weasley's family home for such a bold
opinion 1. Molly Weasley's Brothers even
though Arthur and Molly hid away during
the first Wizarding War the rest of
their family wasn't so lucky during that
time two of Molly Weasley's Brothers
Fabian and Gideon joined the Order of
the Phoenix even though they had some
initial success fighting against
Voldemort's Army of Death Eaters they
were eventually outmatched by a group of
five dark Wizards and was slain as a
result their deaths occurred in the
final year of the war in the same year
the Ginny Weasley was born had they
avoided Conflict for just a while longer
her and waited for Voldemort's first
death at the hands of Lily and Harry
Potter then Fabian and Gideon would have
likely survived but that wasn't what
fate had in store for them and there you
have it 10 shocking facts about the
Weasley family what do you think which
was the most surprising for you was
there anything you wish I added to the
list let me know in the comments below
as always if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget and to live bloody hell
[Music]